a major new Russian offensive in Ukraine
is already underway that's according to
Nato and Ukrainian officials who say
Moscow has spent weeks bolstering troops
in eastern Ukraine ahead of the war's
one-year anniversary on February 24th
Patricia does not present protein do now
is to send in houses or thousands of
more troops
accepting a very high rate of casualty
is
[Music]
new tanks and weapons that Ukraine is
waiting to get from the West may not
arrive in time to hold back the Russians
both sides are preparing both for
offensive action and defensive action we
are coming up to a significant moment in
the war what Ukraine can do with the new
forces and the new weapons it gets from
the West will be critical as winter
gives way to Spring here's how Ukraine
or Russia may try to gain the upper hand
in the coming months
military analysts say the pace of the
war slowed down over winter but there
were key moments
last November Ukraine retook Harrison
the only provincial capital to fall to
Russia since the start of the war
Moscow has been trying to regain
momentum Russia took the Eastern
Ukrainian town of salidar and the
village of clashifka in January and in
the South forces have launched an
offensive in the zaparisa region Bak mut
in eastern Ukraine has been Russia's
main priority according to military
analysts
foreign
exchanges of artillery fire people have
compared it to kind of First World War
battlefield in which there's very little
movement of the front lines but huge
exchanges of artillery
it's around eighty thousand Ukrainian
commanders say only 2 000 remain
Russian media have played up its
strategic value a victory while symbolic
would be a major boost to troop morale
to hold the donbass region Ukraine says
weapons from the U.S and European allies
will play a crucial role over the next
few months Ukraine is expected to
receive more Western weapons including
air defense systems such as the Patriots
tanks Leopard 2 Challenger 2 and M1
Abrams and other armored vehicles
the ukrainians have shown themselves
pretty efficient in Warfare with tanks
that people know how to use them but
they will need training on the different
systems coming in from the west and that
will be something that will need to
happen in the in the coming months
Ukrainian forces have begun training in
the U.S Britain Germany and Spain but
analysts say could be months before
they're fully up to speed Russia accused
the west of trying to prolong the
conflict by supplying weapons to Ukraine
is conflict
meanwhile Russia spent months training
thousands of troops in the country's
West and in Belarus
according to Ukrainian officials
hundreds of thousands of troops have
been mobilized for the offensive in the
donbass
y the ukrainians on their part would be
looking largely to make further gains in
the South toward military Paul and also
actors sort of cut a supply line a Road
between the towns of svatova and a
criminal Russia will likely want to push
the ukrainians further back in the South
so they don't threaten supply lines in
particular those between donbass and the
East and Crimea which the Russians
control in the South Russia's use the
winter to regroup but Western officials
say they don't expect the Russians to
make major territorial gains in the
coming weeks and they hope that with new
weapons you crank and hold Russian
forces back while building on the
momentum they had last year the Western
officials that one talks to don't seem
to believe that the war will be over
this year so although it may be you know
it's very important and potentially
decisive phase ahead there is no
widespread expectation I don't think
that the war will end in 2023
foreign